un marché de noël reporté mais pas
annulé pour les habitants de coignières
c'est un plaisir
ce dimanche ils sont venus nombreux pour
retrouver un semblant de vie sociale en
ce moment on peut dire qu'on est un peu
briguer quand on n'est plus tellement
libre de vivre notre vie comme il faut
surtout au niveau de la convivialité la
famille tout ça là on retrouve des liens
on retrouve des gens c'est une bouffée
d'oxygène pour tous surtout que le
soleil est au rendez vous et les stands
sont particuliers c'est pas un marché de
noël comme d'habitude déjà par le fait
du contexte actuel et chacun expose dans
les stands des choses différentes qui ne
se ressemblent pas pour les exposants
c'est la dernière chance pour vendre
avant noël il espère beaucoup de ce
marché ils sont ravis de retrouver les
clients
ça fait du bien battre
heureuse parce qu'on était très déçu
quand tout a été annulé et puis nous
dire 20 ans finalement c'est décalé
dernier week end avant noël on était
super content de participer pour les
élus les marchés de noël est un moment
convivial important à conserver je pense
que les gens ont besoin de se retrouver
et d'ailleurs voyez on est nombreux
aujourd'hui sur le marché donc c'est un
vrai moment de convivialité qu'on tenait
absolument avant noël à pouvoir pouvoir
faire sur coignières au total près de 30
exposants étaient présents et le plus
attendu de tous le père noël était là et
il a un message à faire passer
il faut que les enfants restent très
pressage et je vous souhaite à tous un
joyeux noël
[Musique]